大家好,下面我为大家介绍一下批量修改功能的使用方法。
在软件的左侧菜单中,您可以选择需要修改的内容。
批量修改分为选择商品修改和上传文件修改。
选择商品可以选择全店商品,也可以选择部分商品。
只选择店铺分组和店铺,点击查询,出现的就是全店的商品。
您还可以进行进一步的筛选,比如选择商品的状态,选择商品所在内幕。
点击查询,出现的就是部分商品。
所有的修改操作都支持定时修改。
接下来,我以批量修改标题为例,演示一下具体的操作流程。
首先,选择要修改的商品。
如果您要修改查询出来的所有商品,可以直接点击必计修改或者定时修改。
这里会显示您查询出的商品数量。
比如,我接下来要把这查询出的2000多个产品参加8月31日的大作活动。
那么,我需要给它的标题加上一些关键字。
然后,设置8月31日零点之行。
设置时间。
点击确认。
点击确定。
我的活动就设置好了。
我也可以只选择几个产品进行修改。
可以直接在页面上进行选择。
我们支持翻页选择。
第一页选好以后,到第二页去。
也可以继续选择。
选好产品以后。
这时候,需要点击选中的商品。
这里也会显示您选中的商品数量。
点击,设置内容,点击确定。
我们的任务就设置好了。
点击,查看修改记录。
可以查看您提交的任务。
下面我们看一下上传文件修改。
上传文件修改需要先下载一个模板。
按照格式填写后上传就可以。
由于时间关系,我提前准备了文件。
我们现在上传一下。
上传好后,可以点击立即修改。
也可以点击定时修改。
同样的,我们可以在查看修改记录这里查看我们的任务提交情况。
点击详细,可以查看具体的修改内容。
如果想要恢复修改前的内容,只需要点击一切恢复,就能轻松还原。
其他内容的批量修改操作方法基本一致,在此就不重复掩饰了。
感谢大家的使用,祝大家生意新龙!